[Music]
damnit
yeah what's up everyone
it's beautiful speaking of dirty shirts
have you ever tried saving money on
laundry well I know a guy that has his
name is Marc and he will go to extreme
measures to save money or to make money
I find this very fascinated I never
heard of extreme cheap stakes before
likes freaking watch people misplace
millions of dollars in loose change
every year and their loss is this
cheapskates gain Wow so he just goes
around like a Marc spends his free time
hunting down dimes nickels and pennies
all over Las Vegas can you just get a
job
does he have a job no I'm self-employed
so what do you do shut shut up legend
I like our cuts from this shot him being
excited about a penny to him wearing a
suit and I run this casino I'm the owner
of this casino I just like extra change
sue me interesting all right well
clearly it's not a cheap steak if it has
a dog okay
that is completely contradictory I will
point out all the fallacies in there
really good person but obviously he's
the extreme cheapskate nine it's got to
be so tough to be friends with a real
cheapskate I never heard that expression
before it's like I don't I wouldn't mind
paying for friends but at the same time
it's like if they assume and it becomes
a standard it's just kind of like all
right hmm I make it sound like I do I
don't but you know what I mean the penny
loafers from back in the day but the
interesting thing about this and this is
how you can really tell okay what's
interesting about the shoes when my
roommates dog
the top I took a marker and I penned in
the black as not to buy a new pair
genius hold up let me do that I'll take
a listen from mark here just paint the
pain away paint the pain away it's not
working it's chocolate
oh I should not just lick it after I
[Laughter]
inked poisoning and he literally will
save money anywhere these shoes and all
my dress shoes I get from the shoe
repair store people drop off the shoes
they forget about them or don't have the
money to pick them up okay I mean fine
so far I can't really blame that you
should take care of your shoes I agree
with that
dude they're your life's way longer you
don't need that many shoes how many
shoes do you add tell me honestly
honestly I should do the same literally
my shoes hold up
look at my shoes they're completely got
all the bunches got the same problem as
mark I'll just paint it up thanks mark
I mean all this I guess you could get
just get shoe backs or whatever whatever
it's cold I don't know I'm not buying it
costs money
Oh mark has a habit of doing things that
are a little bit beyond what I consider
cheapskate mark okay what is rihanna gin
under $60 a month by just regarding
expiration dates and spending no more Oh
chicken I see a problem with that I mean
I get it that's a classic thing if
you're low on money you can buy expired
food and I'm not really here to shame
anyone for trying to save money by the
way it gets it gets more intense then I
basically it's one single item tortillas
50 Cent's Powerbars 50 Cent's cupcakes
50 Cent's peanut butter my health worth
nothing
I'm dying healthily one dollar but his
thrifty habits don't stop there he pays
next to nothing for water each month by
refusing to use it cow an apartment you
still have to pay in the long term on
most dollar fifty on laundry because two
pieces in with everybody else wait you
can keep that washes and dries his
clothes
without spending a dime that seems kind
of shady laundry with you oh he asks
okay no no I wouldn't like that would
you
I don't mind laundry to gag ruined by a
other ever am I an [ __ ] I don't know
a few things not a lot maybe a few
things yeah got him got him
Yeah right yeah hello my name is Marco
it's morning if you mind if I tossed in
a few articles with your laundry man how
do how does he convince them do you mind
if I throw in some water with you thank
you Oh see this is a perfect example of
I wish I was nice but I'm not I'm not
I'm just not see I wish I was nice like
that man he didn't even know about the
cameras I guess sure legit there's good
people out there and it ain't me and it
ain't you even stop pretending couple
things and then you find some mouth to
share a dryer with do you mind if I
throw some longer in with you just a few
items goddamn people are so nice what is
this money some glitch in the matrix
what it's just knowing how to stretch
your money knowing how to make extra
money knowing how to get the best value
I guess I guess like no you know what I
probably would yeah I would I'm just
thinking like if you're I guess I would
assume if someone asked me to throw in
laundry with them they have to be really
poor so I kind of want to help them so I
am a good person of course and it's of
course easy for me to say this in
retrospect but he does not do it he
discerned it to save money for your
money that's the difference well he
won't spend a single cent on laundry
mark does like to gamble but even at the
casinos he's found a way to make sure
he's never parting with his own money
wait what the hell so he's he's saving
money just we can gamble to feed his
gambling addiction why would he do that
he'd buy a good buy G fuel we can but do
anything what a waste
he saves money just to waste it what the
hell there was no money there mark and
you goddamn knowing that I find I don't
spend more than $5 and I only play the
penny slots because you could win up to
$10,000 have you won $10,000 mark I'd
only lose a maximum of five dollars not
a whole page what the hell
what you say money but you order drinks
out what the hell mark you're not a team
stake I keep calling it stink like a
cheap steak that doesn't cut it all
right if I went to a bar the strip would
cost me 12 to 15 dollars but by coming
to a casino
I played the penny slots win money and
drink for free money is free and casinos
money is free and casinos yes that's
what I said
fraid so large alcohol alcohol I'm sorry
I don't know what's wrong with me I
didn't sleep much on 67 cents this is
what one dollar can do
but I'm gambling I know when to stop
most people think oh yeah I'm gonna keep
going they double and double and triple
I'm like no you got to know when to walk
away
Martin all right it was fair enough I
respect that he goes around and always
looking for things to do to try to save
money first time that I realized he was
cheap was definitely when he was trying
to get me to do every single medical
study that I could qualify for in the
past why mark has volunteered in more
than a hundred medical studies and the
riskier the trial the better it pays
what I was doing clinical trials I would
get these scrubs I would take a pill he
takes a cold for daily work I mean yeah
why not in for doing other clinical
trials why not long wait the clothing is
a huge problem for the environment mark
is saving the world guys we should be
thanking him cheap to clean and they
were free these are the scrubs from the
clinical trials these all represent a
part of history for example a part of me
it seems of the Eboli study this is my
what what what this man is fearless
everyone was panicked with my friend and
I did this study never tested on humans
or animals before we were the first in
the country to have it done it's $5,000
for a week so why would I not do it I
couldn't do it I can think of a couple
reasons if you could choose a bullet
wasn't that a super high death rate what
the hell Jesus Christ dude I get saving
money but sacrificing your help I mean
then again someone has to do it so I
guess it's commendable trying to be from
the crazier trials but Mark's full well
into it the two studies that I'm waiting
on that I have not been in yet is a
flatline study this is a really good one
what they do is flatten my heart for one
minute but you still breathe stay there
14 days pays $25,000 14 days you kind of
stepped in and stopped that the second
one that I goddamn FDA stop the heart
stopping surgery maybe it's a really
important one what
he's so like yeah check this out they're
gonna stop my heart for 14 days I might
not come out of line and those goddamn
if ta stop it oh jeez he says it's so
casually I think that's it I'm really
anxious and really excited and waiting
to do is this testicular study what you
do is you go in and you donate one of
your chester goals they replace it with
an artificial one and when you check out
after 14 days you get a check for
$35,000 damn 35 K for adjusted Gail's
did he get would you do it 35 K what
would that be for me yeah yeah I don't
need to oh my god this mint is hardcore
I'll give him that he's hardcore
I may have underestimated him gets free
checkups every month to see if he's a
good candidate for each study free
checkup that's pretty good actually for
a physical examination it's gonna take
some blood make sure that I don't have
high cholesterol diabetes
so what's motivating you to want to go
under the knife and be part of the study
like that
the money has made a second the money so
you're undergoing this serious surgery
where we gonna remove a part of your
body what is there morning my momma
money well at least he's honest I want
to save lives I've read the study about
this about destroys clinical trial and I
think it can help a lot of people's
lives out there so I know this it's just
a big sacrifice for me but I know I'm
doing the money I'm doing it for the
money
[Laughter]
the money yes so I like how he's
correcting the doctor just replacing I
get a new one at one that doesn't hurt
probably don't have to H as much oh okay
have you ever had doctor says I I guess
say the doctor has to check if they're
crazy right is that that has to be a
thing right any a made lunatic I'm just
thinking I don't know what the procedure
is but it has to be a perceived ago for
sure okay and Amy's eyes are so blue
crazy okay and also I gotta check out
your jobs okay now what I'm gonna also
say is you do have the man-boob thing
going on so basically what you've got is
what we call gotta come ask you and so
unfortunately for you you're making
that's a man touching another man's
boobs right there hell yeah
YouTube no I'm joking
testosterone they're making is being
converted into estrogen somebody go get
there's testicle yanked out as part of
this study that it could make the man
boobs bigger man he can make you
testosterone with us so that would be
not nerve you need to bone smart save
the balls
hashtag save marks balls and drop your
drawers
and we just kind of you know examine
both testicles we rub them between our
two fingers and we just palpate around
okay now we'll get lab and EKG and how
to be part of your pre-op evaluations
okay low testosterone levels affect
roughly 39 percent of men
dang dude 39 percent of men watching I'm
sorry I sucks bright efforts in that
chat
39 percent that won't hurt man geez
smoke Pete 39 percent smoke people I was
kidding
a low test result for mark would take
him out of the running for the
testicular study okay Jim Utley there's
hope for his fancy dollar payday so the
risk to you it's pretty significant I'm
not endorsing the surgery Mark's test
reads no I mean yeah yeah abdomen range
set for the clinical trial I'm really
disappointed that I didn't get into this
testicular study but dr. Toma there's
another clinical travel that I can do
you know the telomere line may be going
on testosterone replacement would be a
great thing for you okay have you ever
thought about doing that yeah yeah think
about testosterone replacement all the
time doctor sign me in I've ever thought
oh I'm playing tap tidings while making
videos this has gone too far I'm sorry
you can shoot yourself in the butt with
a shot but at dinner today you'll go
shoot myself in the butt doctor say no
more sign me up I'm ready for this
straight man well it doesn't pay as much
as the testicular removal study mark
does manage to land a spot in a trial
testing testosterone replacement oh I
know where those pills are gonna go
these pills represents to me a thing
that goes up my bling blong I know
because I've done it
yeah I'd blood in my stool a couple
years ago it was fine finger up my butt
no big deal don't have nightmares I will
abide it at all check your butt if you
have to that's all I got to say came a
car insurance payment
seventy-five dollars every Monday cash
fifty dollars every Tuesday 125 movie
times four but it's like eating
backwards it's not that big of a deal
the flashbacks mark it ain't worth it
man
keep looking for pennies man you don't
gotta do that's being me will mark ever
stop being cheap he will definitely not
that's just in his nature really
interesting isn't it the lengths people
go you're being smart about your money
and how you're spending it it's trying
to save by all means but then and then
again it's like yeah well someone has to
do these go at clinical trials who cares
their motivation and I don't know I
don't know what do you think I'm curious
what you guys think for once say a
comment and if you want to subscribe do
so and another another nearly tambourine
goes ping pong maybe we're live
streaming live simha's - right now on
the channel it's been a lot of fun so
far the streams not the game of course
come join the community become a member
yo that's a great way to save five
dollars you wanna save five dollars
check it out it's a great way to save
five dollars you get access to only
thanks discord and a lot of epicness see
you there
take care a tour brofist for a hot tub
you haven't played to Percival later on
the beach
good pack your bags and sit down no one
wants to see your face max tanlines
anyway download tuber simulator for the
perfect beach body
[Music]